[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Endlich ist es soweit, die Sonne ist da!
Die ersten Sonnenstunden kommen schon.
Und bei uns hier in Waghäusel
wird es auch teilweise schon richtig warm,
also so an die 20 bis 24°C.
Natürlich fröstelt es nachts noch ein bisschen,
aber
wir wollen einfach an die frische Luft,
wir wollen raus in unseren Garten
und machen deswegen
jetzt unseren Garten wieder sommerfest.
[Musik]
Das Winterfest-Video habt ihr ja bereits gesehen.
Das Haus habe ich auch schon auf Vordermann gebracht.
Das heißt, drinnen ist alles picobello geputzt.
Der Frühjahrsputz, den habe ich schon hinter mich gebracht.
Jetzt ist der Garten dran,
damit wir wirklich jede Stunde, jede Sekunde
und jede Minute im Garten verbringen können.
Ich muss mich jetzt zuerst einmal um unsere Möbel kümmern.
Die stehen nämlich hier.
Und danach wird euch Murat gleich zeigen,
wie man da hinten die Böden pflegt.
Und wir nehmen euch heute jetzt einfach mal so mit.
Schatz, ist schon komisch, so in deinem Schatten zu stehen.
>> MURAT: Sehr witzig.
Mir ist gerade die Hand, mir ist der Arm eingeschlafen.
Hast du, bist du fertig?
Können wir gemeinsam machen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Okay.
>> MURAT: Ich muss den Boden schrubben.
>> SALLY: Und ich mache die Holzmöbel
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: und zeige euch wie.
>> MURAT: Alles klar.
Oh, der Wind.
>> SALLY: Partnerarbeit!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Teamwork!
Willst du nicht erkannt werden?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Vorsicht!
Wir haben hier unsere nicht überdachte Fläche.
Also hier ist unser Esstisch mit den Stühlen.
Und wir haben auch da eine überdachte Fläche,
unsere Lounge.
Und wir haben an beiden Stellen Holzmöbel,
weil wir uns einfach für die Natürlichkeit entschieden haben.
Und vor allem ist es hier unser Haus, unser Garten,
wir bleiben hier auch.
Das heißt, wir haben wirklich
qualitativ hochwertige Möbel hier gekauft,
weil wir zum einen nachhaltig denken
und zum anderen wollten wir einfach keine Kunststoffmöbel.
Die bleichen aus
und irgendwann gehen sie einfach schneller kaputt.
Holzmöbel muss man aber natürlich pflegen.
Wir haben hier jetzt welche aus Teakholz.
Und Teakholz wird ja auch im Schiffsbau verwendet.
Das heißt, es hält wirklich Feuchtigkeit aus.
Daher musste ich hier den Esstisch und die Stühle
auch gar nicht im Winter wegstellen.
Die waren hier einfach gestanden
ohne Abdeckung.
Auch ganz wichtig.
Wenn man sie abdeckt, gehen sie nämlich hier kaputt.
Und die Möbel hier unter der Überdachung,
die sind sogar gar nicht verbleicht.
Also hier wollten wir tatsächlich,
dass der Tisch so ein bisschen älter aussieht.
Und die da unten, die haben noch ihre natürliche Holzfarbe.
Trotzdem muss ich sie jetzt natürlich pflegen.
Das heißt, sie werden jetzt einmal abgeschliffen
und eben dann auch eingeölt,
damit sie einfach länger halten.
Und so können wir wirklich dafür sorgen,
dass unsere Möbel
hoffentlich eine ganze Weile halten.
Das ist wie bei der Ehe, nicht?
Man muss den Ehemann ja auch pflegen.
Sich darum kümmern, ein bisschen schleifen
und dann wieder einölen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Man sieht es ja gerade.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube nicht, dass du dich beschweren kannst.
>> MURAT: Ja. Ich merke gerade, wie du mich pflegst.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
Hui.
>> MURAT: Geh weg!
Das Ding...
>> SALLY: Ich hole jetzt kurz mein Werkzeug.
Du kannst auch gehen.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also hier sieht man schon,
das ist ein richtig schöner Holztisch.
Aber natürlich hat der
durch die ganzen Grillevents hier und das Essen
und das Basteln und Backen und Verzehren
natürlich auch einige Flecken bekommen,
wie hier ein paar Fettflecken.
Oder natürlich auch, weil er eben unter freiem Himmel steht,
kommt natürlich auch mal Vogelkot drauf und macht Flecken.
Und deswegen möchte ich
den Tisch jetzt einfach ein bisschen abschleifen.
Ich habe hier jetzt ein 150er Schleifpapier,
also so mittelfein.
Ich mache es jetzt hier mit dem Exzenterschleifer,
weil es schneller geht.
Aber man kann die Holzmöbel natürlich auch
mit der Hand abreiben, abschleifen,
dauert halt nur ein bisschen länger.
Indoor würde ich empfehlen, einen Mundschutz zu tragen,
eben wegen dem feinen Staub gleich.
Aber outdoor geht es eigentlich auch ganz gut ohne.
Ja. Das mache ich jetzt hier,
mache auch die Armlehnen an den Stühlen
und dann gleich noch dort drüben
die Terrassenmöbel.
Dort haben wir einige Wasserflecken,
weil der Murat mit dem Hochdruckreiniger
immer mal schön die Terrasse reinigt
und die Möbel dann halt nicht wegstellt.
Ist nicht schlimm.
Man würde es auch nicht sehen,
weil eben gleich Polster noch darauf kommen.
Aber ich schleife die auch kurz ab,
kann sie einölen
und dann sind sie wieder fertig und bereit für den Sommer.
[Musik]
Und während ich mich jetzt hier um die Möbel kümmere,
zeigt der Murat euch,
wie er sich um den Holzboden kümmert.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
Während die Sally die Terrasse aufräumt,
mache ich mich mal im Nutzgarten zu schaffen.
Das ist hier unser Nutzgarten.
Und hier seht ihr die ganzen Hochbeete.
Und jetzt geht es ja eigentlich einfach um
das Get-Ready-for-Summer oder Get-Ready-for-Frühling,
wie auch immer, wie ihr es nennen wollt.
Dieser Holzboden ist jetzt ein Jahr alt.
Und ganz am Anfang sah der aus wie unsere Wand da vorne.
Und durch ein Jahr, durch die ganze Verwitterung,
durch das ganze Wasser, durch die Sonne,
gerade auf dem Bodenbereich,
weil da Wasser oft liegen bleibt,
vergraut das Holz.
Das ist eine natürliche Patina.
Um so ein Holz muss man sich natürlich kümmern.
Die Kids laufen hier barfuß rum.
Ich laufe hier barfuß rum.
Und nach einem Jahr sieht ein Holzboden ungefähr so aus.
Ihr seht es jetzt hier zum Beispiel.
Wie gesagt, man muss nur mal anschauen,
wo eben im Holz solche Spreißen rausschauen,
damit man es nicht in die Füße reinkriegt.
Und das muss man abschleifen.
Wenn man es richtig macht,
holt man sich einen coolen Parkettschleifer,
den leiht man sich irgendwo aus,
macht einmal,
komplett mit dem Parkettschleifer geht man da drüber.
Im ersten Jahr würde ich es noch nicht machen.
Im zweiten Jahr...
Weil es ja auch Geld kostet.
Im zweiten Jahr würde ich es dann machen.
Aber im ersten Jahr, wenn man solche Flecken hier sieht,
wie hier zum Beispiel,
dann würde ich einfach hier ein Schleifgerät nehmen
und mit diesem Schleifgerät
einfach mal über diese Stelle drüber,
dass das hier alles weg ist.
[Musik]
Und jetzt ist natürlich auch die Pflege gefragt.
Pflege heißt für mich,
den ganzen Boden richtig schön sauber machen.
Das werde ich jetzt abkärchern
und nach dem Abkärchern noch mal schön
mit einem coolen Leinöl drüber,
damit das Holz wieder Leben bekommt,
ein bisschen Öl bekommt.
Und dann passiert das auch nicht, dass das Holz,
wenn es mal trocken wird in einem heißen Sommer,
dass es wegbricht, dass es spröde wird.
Und das ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Und das machen wir jetzt alles
und da zeige ich euch ein paar coole Tricks
und vor allem, was ihr nicht machen solltet.
Wenn ihr so einen Holzboden bearbeitet,
nicht pur mit dem Hochdruckreiniger!
Dafür gibt es extra Aufsätze.
Wenn ihr es nämlich wirklich
pur mit dem Hochdruckreiniger macht,
dann schießt ihr hier das ganze Holz weg.
Das seht ihr hier.
Das habe ich nämlich schon gemacht,
um euch das mal zu zeigen.
Gerade an dieser Platte hier
da schleife ich jetzt gleich noch mal drüber.
Aber das passiert, wenn ihr wirklich
mit 160 bar ans Holz hingeht.
Dann schießt ihr die ganzen Fasern weg.
Das ist nicht gut.
Das heißt, dafür gibt es extra Vorsätze.
Und den Vorsatz zeige ich euch mal jetzt.
Und jetzt machen wir Folgendes:
Wir koppeln hier
dieses Teil hier ab
und
haben hierzu
diese Holzbürste.
Zack.
So sieht es aus ohne die Bürste.
Oh. Entschuldigung, Josh.
Und jetzt schön drüberfahren.
Ihr seht sicher,
ihr seht auch schon, wie es sich schon leicht löst,
der ganze Schmodder.
[Musik]
So. Ihr seht, es hat super funktioniert.
Der Boden sieht schon ganz anders aus.
Das ganz Graue ist weg.
Jetzt ist es so leicht silbern geworden.
Und jetzt gehe ich...
Wenn es getrocknet ist,
gehe ich noch mal mit dem Öl drüber.
Das zeige ich euch auch noch ganz kurz.
Und dann ist der Boden sicher, safe,
sieht cool aus
und er hält eine lange Zeit.
So.
Was ich auch machen kann,
das ist auch eine coole Geschichte,
das benutze ich normalerweise fürs Auto
und zwar ist das diese Bürste.
Ich habe einmal diese Grobbürste und eine feine Bürste.
Und mit dieser Grobbürste ist es auch richtig cool.
Die habe ich jetzt da drauf gemacht.
Jetzt stelle ich es wieder ein.
Okay.
Etwa mittlere Stufe.
So.
Jetzt kann ich noch hier
wie – normalerweise macht man es mit dem Auto.
[Musik]
Und gerade wegen dem Wasserverbrauch
ist ganz, ganz wichtig,
hier, wenn ihr unsere alten Videos schon gesehen habt,
das Wasser, was ich verwende,
ist komplett Regenwasser.
Wir haben eine riesengroße,
20.000 Liter große Zisterne.
Und da haben wir Regenwasser drin.
Das heißt, das ganze Wasser, was ich hier benutze,
kommt direkt aus meiner Zisterne.
Und deswegen
kostet mich das auch nichts.
Da sieht man wieder,
die Schwaben,
wie haben es halt drauf.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So.
Damit wir hier heute noch fertig werden,
lasse ich hier Volkan weitermachen.
>> VOLKAN: Nein!
>> SALLY: Und ich kann jetzt schon mal
starke Männer noch holen.
Also Volkan ist auch stark.
Aber du kannst hier weitermachen.
Und ich hole noch ein paar starke Männer,
um den Tisch wegzutragen.
Und dann wird er nämlich eingeölt.
Und das macht ihr am besten wirklich nicht hier
auf den Fliesen oder auf euren Via Platten,
sondern auf dem Rasen,
damit das Öl nicht auf eure Fliesen tropft
und keine hässlichen Spuren und Flecken hinterlässt.
Okay, Murat, wir zwei schaffen das nicht.
Wir holen uns noch ein paar Helfer, oder?
>> MURAT: Wieso nicht? Wir schaffen das.
>> SALLY: Schaffen wir das?
>> MURAT: Ha, ja. Komm. Wir schaffen das.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wir haben es auch geholt.
>> MURAT: Ah, ja.
>> SALLY: Ach.
Ihr schafft das ja auch zu zweit.
>> MURAT: Das hätte ich alleine geschafft,
wenn ich nicht einen Tennisarm hätte.
Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter.
>> SALLY: Ich wusste gar nicht, wie stark ihr seid.
>> MURAT: So.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Oh, sind die schwer!
Warte.
Samira, wie kannst du das?
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Danke, Schatz. Hilfst du Papa?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Okay.
Die Möbel sind jetzt fertig geschliffen.
Ich habe sie jetzt
mit dem Team, mit unseren Freunden,
einfach auf den Rasen gestellt.
Ich kann jetzt hier nämlich erst mal Grundputz machen.
Das heißt für mich saugen,
alles an Grobschmutz hier erst mal wegmachen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier einfach mit unserem Outdoor-Sauger.
Das ist so ein Nass- und Trockensauger
und auch Gebläse.
Das heißt, man kann auch schön
das Auto damit mal auspusten
oder Laub wegblasen
und wegpusten.
Und ja, jetzt sauge ich hier erst mal den Schmutz weg.
Und dann geht es hier schon direkt an den Grünspan.
Also da machen wir dann wirklich
die Terrasse richtig schön blitzeblank.
Hier ist auch alles ziemlich schmutzig geworden.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt sind wir hier mit der Samira zusammen
am Tisch, wo die Mama schon abgeschliffen hat.
Und jetzt werden wir das natürlich bearbeiten.
Der Tisch steht draußen.
Jetzt brauchen wir natürlich einen Schutz.
Und da nehmen wir hier
dieses Firnis.
Das ist ein Leinöl, 100% natürlich.
Und
das macht die Samira jetzt.
Das ist rein biologisch.
Brauchst dir gar keine Sorgen machen, mein Schatz.
Trotzdem ziehst du deine Handschuhe an.
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
Aber, Papa, warum habe ich zwei linke Handschuhe?
>> MURAT: Du hast zwei linke Handschuhe?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ach.
Die sind wahrscheinlich vom Onkel Güni.
Der hat nämlich zwei linke Hände.
Und das sind seine Handschuhe. Weißt du?
>> SAMIRA: Aha.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Jetzt gehst du ganz leicht drüber.
Okay?
So.
Und dann tust du hier
drüber. Okay?
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: So.
Man kann das auch natürlich...
Besser ist es,
wenn man es mit einem Tuch macht.
Und zwar ganz normal ein Baumwolltuch nehmen
und dann schön einreiben.
Das geht auch.
Das macht man hier rein, Schatz.
Siehst du das?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Guck. Einreiben. Dann tropft es auch nicht so.
Das ist dann noch besser.
Aber das, was du am besten kannst, okay?
Ich würde vielleicht noch mal das Tuch nehmen,
weil sonst tropft es zu arg.
Wichtig,
ganz, ganz wichtig,
– das ist ein Gefahrenhinweis –
wenn das Tuch nachher komplett mit Leinöl getränkt ist,
bitte nicht zusammenknüllen und in eine Ecke werfen.
Weil so sind schon viele Schreinereien abgebrannt,
weil das kann sich dann entzünden.
Also wirklich, wenn ihr so ein Tuch benutzt mit Leinöl,
wenn ihr mit Leinöl hantiert,
dieses Tuch irgendwo gut zum Lüften aufhängen
und ja nicht zusammenknüllen in eine Ecke.
Hast du es verstanden, Schatz?
Sonst brennt die Bude ab und wir sind nicht versichert.
Okay?
Alles klar.
Also dann nimmst du das.
Wie gesagt,
so ein bisschen.
Und dann schön einmassieren.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> MURAT: Okay?
Alles klar.
>> SAMIRA: Darf ich?
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
So.
Während Samira hier
das alles einölt, die ganzen Möbel,
und die Sally staubsaugt,
tue ich hier die Stühle ein bisschen abdampfen.
Und hier gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Und zwar, einmal haben wir hier:
Das ist hart.
Das ist soft.
Und dann gibt es noch den Mix.
Und der ist zum Schmutzlösen.
Das ist dann wie so ein Drehwurm.
Seht ihr das?
So.
Und so tue ich jetzt mal alles hier
abkärchern.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Hier haben wir richtige Keramikplatten.
Es gibt auch wieder verschiedene Arten,
Terrassenbeläge zu machen.
Ihr habt ja vorher drüben gesehen,
ich habe da Holz.
Hier habe ich Keramik, Stein.
Und bei den Steinplatten ist es so,
wir haben uns dazu entschieden
– man kann ja Fugen reinmachen.
Und oftmals sind Kieselsteine drin.
Bei den Kieselsteinen ist immer das Problem,
da wächst irgendwann mal Gras raus.
Und das wollten wir nicht.
Deswegen haben wir Harz reingemacht.
Trotzdem schützt dieses Harz nicht vor Grünspan,
vor richtig Grünspan.
Das sieht man auch hier in diesen ganzen Fugen hier.
Und den möchten wir natürlich rauskriegen.
Das geht mit dieser Bürste nicht so gut.
Es würde gehen mit viel, viel Mechanik.
Mit viel Druck würde es auch mit der Bürste gehen.
Aber dafür gibt es extra diesen Terrassenreiniger.
Der wird auch einfach
an den Hochdruckreiniger angeschlossen.
Und mit wenig Chemie
kann man hier einfach die Terrasse nachher reinigen
mit dem Hochdruckreiniger.
Wie das geht, das zeige ich euch jetzt gleich.
>> SALLY: Vielleicht kann man da noch was dazusagen.
>> MURAT: Ja? Was denn?
>> SALLY: Wir haben früher...
Erinnerst du dich noch daran,
als wir im anderen Stadtteil gewohnt haben?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Erste Wohnung?
>> SALLY: Also ich sage jetzt nicht die Straße.
Ach, doch.
Caldicotstraße, da haben wir früher gewohnt.
Und wir haben in einem Mehrfamilienhaus gewohnt.
Und mein Papa, der hat immer außerhalb der Arbeitszeit
dann noch den Hausmeisterdienst gemacht.
Und für uns war das,
für uns Kinder, vor allem mein kleiner Bruder und ich
– wir sind halt zusammen aufgewachsen.
Die anderen drei, die sind schon größer.
Und für uns war die Kehrwoche
immer so das Highlight der Woche
Freitag und Samstag.
>> MURAT: Ja, für uns auch.
>> SALLY: Das war wirklich so!
>> MURAT: Absolut!
>> SALLY: Wir haben die Kehrwoche
dann fürs ganze Haus gemacht,
das heißt 22 Familien als Einwohner.
Und wir haben dann draußen immer gekärchert.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und übrigens ist die Kehrwoche,
es ist wirklich kein Spaß.
Man sagt immer, das ist ein Mythos.
Das ist im Schwabenland,
jetzt bei den Badenern nicht so hier.
>> SALLY: Doch!
Bei uns jeder Freitag und Samstag war Kehrwoche!
>> MURAT: Im Schwabenland war es wirklich so,
ist es, samstags wird gekärchert. Da ist
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: nämlich die Kehrwoche.
Und deswegen ist es ein Heiligtum.
Wer das nicht...
>> SALLY: Also bei uns war Freitag immer indoor,
also innen Treppenhaus, Geländer und so weiter.
Das habe ich mit meiner Mama gemacht.
Und samstags war outdoor mit dem Papa.
Und da habe ich mich immer
draußen auf die große Kehrmaschine gesetzt,
auf die gelbe, große.
Da war ich so alt wie du, Samira, oder sogar noch kleiner.
Ich habe mich drauf gesetzt
und der Papa hat dann immer schön
– Sagt man das bei euch auch? – gekärchert halt.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Genug Sentimentalität.
Jetzt geht es weiter und zwar technisch.
Und ich zeige auch, was man falsch machen kann,
weil das habe ich auch schon falsch gemacht.
Ihr könnt nämlich auch mit einem Hochdruckreiniger
auch einiges kaputt machen
und zwar, wenn ihr den falsch handhabt.
Haltet immer diesen Abstand ab beim Hochdruckreiniger
von 20 bis 30cm. Dann kann nichts passieren.
Gerade bei diesen Fugen ist es ganz wichtig.
Den Fehler, was ich schon gemacht habe,
und zwar, ich bin direkt mit dem Hochdruckreiniger
drauf gegangen,
bevor ich diese Bürste noch nicht bestellt habe,
und habe hier die Fugen weggeschossen
mit dem Hochdruckreiniger.
Da muss ich jetzt wieder Harz auffüllen.
Das heißt,
wenn ihr so...
So ein Gerät ist richtig cool,
weil es ist wirklich eine schonende Art und Weise
und ihr schießt euch nicht die Fugen weg
oder die Steine, die Kieselsteine, was drin sind.
Das könnt ihr machen, wenn ihr
Waschbetonplatten habt und da richtig Moos drauf sitzt.
Da ist es völlig in Ordnung.
Könnt ihr auch machen. Ist mir egal.
Aber hier bei diesen Platten ganz wichtig,
nehmt da
diese Bürste, diesen Bürstenaufsatz.
Das ist wirklich genial!
Und hier seht ihr diesen Grünspan.
Und den
muss ich jetzt wegbekommen.
Das bekomme ich weg mit der ganzen Bürste.
Ich komme mir gerade vor wie bei
"Hör mal, wer da hämmert".
>> SALLY: Schatz, ich mache das!
>> MURAT: Ich erkläre euch jetzt, wie das...
>> SALLY: Ich mache das!
Das ist nämlich eine einfache Arbeit.
Mach du lieber was Aufwendiges.
>> MURAT: Also Heidi ist da.
Dann gehe ich
ans Ölen.
Dann zeigst du, wie es geht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay. Ist ganz einfach.
Dann gehe ich rüber.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also wir wollen jetzt die Terrasse reinigen ohne viel Chemie.
Das heißt, ihr könnt auch den Grünspan entfernen
mit einigen Mitteln, Reinigungsmitteln.
Da gibt es überall Reiniger wie Sand am Meer.
Aber, wie gesagt, mit Druck
und ohne Chemie funktioniert es eben auch.
So machen wir das jetzt hier.
Jetzt wollte der Murat schön die leichte Arbeit machen
und mich wieder was
Schwieriges machen lassen.
Nö! Nicht mit mir!
Okay. Also ich kann jetzt hier
die Terrasse schön befeuchten.
Ich habe jetzt hier nämlich einmal hier einen Drücker.
Da kommt dann ein schöner Wasserstrahl,
auch gerade für Ecken und so Kanten geeignet,
wo man eben nicht so gut dran kommt.
Und dann habe ich hier einen Drücker.
Und dann rotiert das Ganze
und ich kann wirklich schön die Terrasse reinigen,
ohne selber Kraft aufwenden zu müssen
und, wie gesagt, ohne Reiniger.
Ich fange jetzt hinten an.
Am besten immer von hinten nach vorne.
So habt ihr zum einen einen Überblick
und ihr lauft nicht über die saubere Terrasse rüber.
Hier im Lieferumfang war sogar ein Reiniger dabei
für Steine, also jetzt gerade hier für Fliesen.
Wenn man den benutzen möchte, kann man den einfach
hier reinklicken
und auch eben mit benutzen.
Ich probiere es jetzt aber zuerst mal ohne.
Und, wenn ich ihn doch brauche,
– also wir sind ja erst den zweiten Sommer hier.
Das heißt, so starke Verschmutzungen haben wir nicht.
Aber ich bin trotzdem erschrocken.
Denn, wenn man sich die Fugen anschaut,
wir haben echt schon viel Grünspan da.
Vielleicht geht es ohne, aber vielleicht brauche ich auch
einfach ein bisschen vom Reiniger.
[Musik]
Da vorne auf der Terrasse,
da geht es ja noch so mit der Verschmutzung.
Da haben wir wirklich nur mehr den Grünspan.
Hier unten auf der Terrasse,
weil es eben überdacht ist und kein Regen dran kommt,
haben wir echt richtig starke Verschmutzungen.
Und da würde ich mit einer Bürste schon ewig stehen
zum Putzen und deswegen nehme ich hier
auch den Hochdruckreiniger,
weil es wirklich viel einfacher geht
und wirklich ohne Chemie geht.
[Musik]
Guckt mal.
Hier habe ich jetzt noch so Flecken auf der Terrasse.
Das sind Rostflecken.
Das ist einfach,
wenn wir mal ein Werkzeug draußen vergessen
und es regnet und es fängt dann eben an zu rosten,
dann gibt es auch Flecken auf der Terrasse.
Die habe ich jetzt nicht weggekriegt.
Aber da gibt es einen ganz einfachen Trick
und zwar einfach etwas Cola.
Cola löst nämlich auch bei Autos,
bei Felgen und Fahrrädern
die Rostflecken.
Sollte man daher vielleicht nicht trinken,
sondern wirklich nur zum Putzen benutzen.
Und dann schön drüberschrubben.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Nachdem ich den Boden
sauber gemacht habe, öle ich den jetzt mit dem Leinöl nach.
Ich habe hier einfach so eine Rolle genommen,
habe einen Bambusstiel
gefunden im Garten.
Wie heißt es?
Faul darfst du sein, aber nicht dumm.
So.
Und jetzt tue ich hier alles schön einölen,
den ganzen Boden.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt ist die Terrasse sauber.
Jetzt sind unsere Möbel hier dran,
also so die Regale,
damit ich auch wieder
unsere schöne Sommerdeko anbringen kann.
Ich mache jetzt alles hier mit unserem Allesreiniger.
Den habe ich selber gemacht.
Da gibt es auch schon ein Rezept auf meinem Kanal.
Zum einen riecht er gut
und er macht wirklich alle Verschmutzungen weg.
[Musik]
Das ist wieder so typisch!
Männer machen immer nur sauber, was man sieht.
Aber ihr müsst auch mal die Möbel umdrehen,
vor allem die Bodenmöbel.
Also so die Lounge, die ist ja ziemlich am Boden.
Und da hat sich im Winter schon einiges angesammelt,
gerade die ganzen Pollen und hier Spinnen und
Schmutz.
[Musik]
So.
Hilfst du mir gleich mit den Polstern?
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
Okay.
>> SALLY: Andersrum! Andersrum!
>> MURAT: O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Weil da ist ja die Ablage.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und bei mir ist die Ecke.
>> SALLY: Halt! Geh weiter, weiter, weiter.
>> MURAT: Weiter.
>> SALLY: Runter.
Warte. Mein Fuß.
>> MURAT: So. Perfekt!
>> SALLY: So.
Weil hier kommt jetzt die Ecke.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Und hier das Kleine.
>> SALLY: Hier ist die Ecke.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ja.
Jetzt müssen wir noch den ganzen Krimskrams
und den ganzen Müll holen.
>> SALLY: Das ist kein Krimskrams! Das ist Dekoration!
>> MURAT: Ach so. Okay.
Dann holen wir die Dekoration.
>> SALLY: Unser Lifestyle.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Wüstenblumen.
>> SALLY: Das sind keine Wüstenblumen!
>> MURAT: Was sind das?
Stroh?
>> SALLY: Das sind schöne Blumen. Die wachsen wieder.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Doch. Die muss ich nur hier zurückschneiden.
[Musik]
Murat, man sieht dich gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Was? Hast du mich nicht erkannt?
Ich habe mich hinter dem Busch versteckt.
Hat das Ding dein Papa gebaut?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Kannst du ihm mal sagen,
dass es im 21. Jahrhundert noch Räder gibt,
die sich drehen?
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Okay. Das wohin?
>> SALLY: Warte.
Standort: Sonne.
Hier Standort: Sonne.
Also die können wir eigentlich
auch hier.
Weißt du? Dann haben wir hier so eine schöne, bunte Ecke.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch
beim Christian ein paar Blumen bestellt
aus Mauer.
Und
die werde ich jetzt demnächst auch einpflanzen.
Also ich lasse die jetzt erst mal hier,
gucke dann auch, wie es mir gefällt so vom Standort her.
Aber ich finde, Pflanzen machen die Terrasse
und den Balkon einfach schön
und gemütlich.
Ich meine, wir haben ja hier einen schönen Garten,
aber, wenn ich jetzt hier so schaue,
so die Pflanzen hier oder die an der Säule
oder gerade hier.
Aber ich lasse die erst mal stehen.
Denn
heute kann ich nichts mehr einpflanzen.
Ich bin echt richtig kaputt heute.
>> MURAT: Das ist so ein Terrassenteppich.
Der kann ruhig
nass werden.
So.
Der bleibt den ganzen Sommer draußen,
wenn er nicht wegfliegt.
>> SALLY: Aber, Schatz, der fliegt doch immer weg.
>> MURAT: Der fliegt nicht weg. Mach dir keine Sorgen.
>> SALLY: Ich bestelle einfach ein Sonnen-
eine Sonnenliege drauf.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> SALLY: Dann fliegt er nicht mehr weg.
Der fliegt nicht weg.
Ich klebe ihn fest.
So.
>> SALLY: Das ist eine Picknickdecke für die Kids.
Die sitzen hier echt voll gern im Sommer
und spielen einfach da drauf.
So eine Liege wäre aber auch schön.
Guckt mal. Das ist auch eine ganz besondere Aloe Vera.
Richtig schön!
Und, dass eine Aloe Vera so eine Blume dran hat,
so eine Blüte dran hat, ist wirklich ganz besonders!
[Musik]
Wenn du den jetzt fallen lässt
auf die frisch geputzte Fliese und die kaputtgeht...
>> MURAT: Die geht nicht kaputt.
Die ist Made in Germany.
Das kann nicht kaputtgehen.
So.
Jetzt sind wir fertig
und zwar hier.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Richtig cool!
>> SALLY: Der Terrassenboden glänzt wieder.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Grünspan ist weg.
Alle Fliesen sind wieder sauber.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Die Hochbeete sind sauber.
Dahinten, da
hatte ich
im Winter schon mit meinem Papa
so ein bisschen was weggeschnitten.
Und der Papa schneidet generell gerne Pflanzen zurück.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber das wächst hier alles wieder nach
jetzt im Frühjahr.
Und die Deko steht jetzt auch wieder.
Es gibt noch ein paar Pflanzen,
die wir dann noch rausstellen.
Aber es kommt vielleicht noch ein bisschen Frost in der Nacht.
Deswegen bleibe ich noch vorsichtig.
Auch der Olivenbaum
bleibt erst mal mit Heizung.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: So ab nächster Woche können wir den
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: dann ohne.
>> MURAT: Und
hier das ist auch jetzt alles geölt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Und das ist halt...
Das ist halt das Schöne,
das ist halt Holz.
Das ist einfach schön.
Das sieht einfach toll aus.
Deswegen kein Kunststoff
für uns jetzt zumindest.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ja.
Aber ihr seht, es ist auch ziemlich viel Arbeit.
Denkt immer an den Spruch:
Was du besitzt, das besitzt auch dich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Und deswegen...
>> SALLY: Ich gucke mir jetzt mal
die Holzterrasse von dir an.
>> MURAT: Ja. Dann gehen wir mal kurz zur Holzterrasse.
Was ich dort gemacht habe,
das war nämlich auch der Hammer.
[Musik]
Guck mal, wie schön die ist.
O mein Gott! Geh weg von mir!
Geh weg von mir!
>> SALLY: Nein. Die ist voll schön!
>> MURAT: O mein Gott! Geh weg von mir!
>> SALLY: Die macht nichts!
>> MURAT: Okay.
Hier bin ich auch fertig geworden.
Ihr wisst noch, wie es vorher aussah,
und nachher sieht es so aus.
[Musik]
Ich finde Holz einfach genial.
Aber
es hat mir jetzt einen ganzen Tag weggenommen.
Und das ist eigentlich schon viel.
Hätte ich den Hochdruckreiniger nicht gehabt,
dann hätte es noch länger gedauert.
>> SALLY: Bestimmt fünf Tage.
>> MURAT: Da hätte ich alles abschleifen müssen.
Und nächstes Jahr schauen wir uns den Boden mal an.
Vielleicht muss ich komplett mit dem Parkettschleifer
komplett einmal drüber.
Kommt drauf an.
Also, wie gesagt, da muss man echt Bock drauf haben.
Ich würde es
noch mal machen.
So.
Bei den nächsten Videos
mache ich so ein cooles Teichvideo.
Ich habe den Teich ja letztes Jahr angelegt.
Und ich habe noch keine Fische reingemacht,
weil ich...
Wo ist meine Frau?
Die ist weg.
So.
Ich habe noch keine Fische reingemacht,
weil ich erst mal gucken wollte,
wie so ein Teich funktioniert,
wie alles,
was man da alles machen muss.
Der Teich ist auch richtig schön sauber.
Und jetzt dieses Jahr möchte ich Fische reinmachen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr einen coolen Tipp habt für Fische...
Ich möchte keine Kois haben.
Die sind zu teuer.
Ich will normale Fische haben.
Vielleicht gibt es auch Fische, wo ich essen kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn ihr ein paar coole Tipps habt,
schreibt es in die Kommentare mit Fischen.
Und...
>> SALLY: Kann man nicht lieber
selber im Teich schwimmen?
>> MURAT: Nein, kann man nicht.
>> SALLY: Warum?
>> MURAT: Weil da sind die Fische drin.
Nimm das mit. Das ist von deiner Tochter.
>> SALLY: Das kannst du benutzen.
Das ist so ein
Bauch-weg-Hula-Hoop.
>> MURAT: Der Reifen hier?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: So?
Dafür brauche ich wahrscheinlich drei Reifen.
>> SALLY: Guck.
Ta-taa!
>> MURAT: Soll ich mal machen?
>> SALLY: Bauch weg.
>> MURAT: Gibt mal her.
Halte mal meinen Hammer.
>> SALLY: Du bist der Hammer.
>> MURAT: Pass auf.
Okay. Geht nicht.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Der Bauch geht nicht weg, aber der Reifen schon.
So.
Dann gehen wir weiter
und zeigen euch, was wir drüben gemacht haben.
>> SALLY: Hier.
Hammer gegen Hula-Hoop.
>> MURAT: So. Hier nehmen wir den Holzklotz.
Woah!
Mein Gott!
Was gibt es?
Deko wird auch immer schwerer!
>> SALLY: Ich kann sogar damit laufen!
Läuft die Kamera schon?
>> MURAT: Mein Auge tut weh. Ich habe...
>> JOSH: Noch fünf Minuten ausruhen.
>> SALLY: Ich bin so kaputt!
>> MURAT: Ich auch.
Ich habe mir mit so einem...
>> SALLY: Hammer?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Mit so einer Pflanze ins Auge reingestochen.
Aua.
>> SALLY: Oh, Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja. Auf jeden Fall das Video ist fertig.
>> SALLY: Also das Video ist ja auch gleich fertig.
Aber das, der Garten ist endlich wieder sauber.
Garten,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Terrasse.
Und
ich muss echt sagen, ich bin fix und fertig.
Also ich freue mich einfach nur noch auf eine warme Dusche,
auf meinen Tee und aufs Bett.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber ich bin glücklich, dass wir es gemacht haben.
Denn endlich können wir wieder draußen sitzen.
Die Polster sind wieder da.
So ein paar Kleinigkeiten müssen wir noch machen.
Die Pflanzen werden wir noch einsetzen,
also dann auch wieder die Hochbeete bepflanzen.
Und da warten wir aber noch ein, zwei Wochen, oder?
Bis das Wetter wieder schöner wird.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil heute war es relativ frisch,
aber zum Putzen perfekt.
Denn beim Putzen wird es einem ja auch schön warm.
Und ja, jetzt können wir zumindest schon mal
die Sonnenstunden draußen wieder nutzen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat das Video gefallen.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
dann schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Wie gesagt, den Frühjahrsputz gibt es auch schon
auf meinem Kanal.
Reiniger selber machen gibt es auf meinem Kanal.
Also dieses Jahr war wirklich,
2020, das sauberste Jahr
>> SALLY & MURAT: ever.
>> MURAT: Ever ever.
>> SALLY: Und ja,
dann freue ich mich auf euer Feedback.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und wir sehen uns ganz bald wieder,
wenn wir unsere Pflanzen einsetzen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Und jetzt gehe ich zum Arzt,
weil ich glaube, ich habe mir mit so einer Pflanze
ins Auge gestochen.
Siehst du das?
Ich sehe nichts mehr.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Wer bist du?
>> SALLY: Ojemine.
>> MURAT: Okay. Ich räume auf.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Macht es gut! Macht es besser!
>> SALLY: Also die Gartenzeit ist eröffnet.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Hoffentlich hat es euch Spaß gemacht.
Hoffentlich habt ihr was gelernt.
>> SALLY: Bestimmt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm. Husch, husch!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
[Musik]